so we've been discussing the case of
james-younger over this over the week
and after raising awareness of the case
this week and getting this hashtag
campaign hashtag protect james-younger
going it looks like some some crucial
people are taking notice the governor of
Texas Greg Abbott has said that his
Attorney General is going to look into
it he's also going to have the social
services look into the case as well some
state legislators have said they're
gonna propose a bill that would ban
giving puberty blockers to
gender-confused children ted cruz issued
a statement last night
dan Crenshaw has spoken out the
mainstream media is actually taking
notice finally they're reporting on it
the Washington Post did or did a report
the report obviously was was unfair and
biased in favor of the mom but still
they are at least taking notice which
which they would prefer not to do but I
think we forced them to so III think
that it would be fair to say that our
our efforts our speaking out about this
situation really has a lot to do with
these developments turns out that
hashtag campaigns actually can't
accomplish something what what do you
know who would have thought and maybe
this will leave an impression on
Republican politicians not just in Texas
but on the federal level as well I've
been saying this for years that this
issue is a winner for Republicans the
Senate should should get together they
should pass legislation immediately that
bans the chemical castration of children
let the House Democrats if they want to
if they feel comfortable with it let
them come out explicitly in favor of
chemically castrating gender-confused
children but force them to take a stand
out in one way or another you pass the
bill and then let the Democrats let them
make their case for why it's actually
okay to chemically castrate
eight-year-olds let them do that either
way no matter how they do if they come
out in defense of it then everyone sees
what a bunch of barbaric lunatics these
people are or they pass the bill in
which case children are protected
whichever way they go it will benefit
society and it will benefit benefit
children so there
no reason not to do this this is a this
is a winning issue for Republicans and
more important than that than the fact
that it's a winner politically which it
definitely is is just that it's it's the
right thing to do okay so um but what I
want really want to start with today I
want to talk about this hearing on the
hill yesterday with Mark Zuckerberg
where the Democrats transparently went
fishing for viral moments by taking
turns interrogating him with random and
irrelevant questions basically treating
him like a murder suspect it was easily
the most embarrassing moment the
Democrats have had in at least the last
16 hours and we'll get to that in a
minute but first a word from calming
comfort you know like a lot of people
these days I have trouble falling asleep
and that's that's that's tough because
scientists say if you knew this but
scientists say that human beings need
sleep you all you actually are supposed
to sleep and it's unhealthy if you don't
it's kind of what it means to be human
and that's where calming comfort by
sharper image comes in the luxurious
weighted blanket that helps you relax so
you can fall asleep and stay asleep
naturally calming Comfort is designed
with high density comfort field to
provide exactly the right amount of
weight to help relax the body and it
mimics the soothe sort of feeling of
being hugged for less stress at a
restful night's sleep calming comfort
applies an even amount of pressure over
your body to help the production of
serotonin and melatonin simulating deep
touch pressure stimulation and this is
really important also at least for me
calming comfort is 100% machine washable
and and also dryer safe and that's good
because my wife knows that if I am on
laundry Duty I'm just throwing
everything into the washer on the same
setting and then throwing it into the
dryer on the same setting without
checking the labels so it's best to have
only machine washable stuff in the house
the calming comfort weighted blanket
comes with a 90-day anxiety free stress
free best night's sleep of your life
guarantee from sharper image right now
just for our listeners you can go to
calming comfort blanket calm use promo
code Walsh at checkout and receive 50%
off of the displayed price again that's
calming comfort blanket dot-com promo
code Walsh and because you can't put a
price on a great night's sleep
go online at common comfort blanket
common use promo code Walsh for your
special discount today so the the suck
man
as I call him as of just now and I'm
gonna stop calling them that I'm gonna
retire that already was on Capitol Hill
yesterday testifying before the House
Financial Services Committee about Libra
which is Facebook's new cryptocurrency
concept actually it's not just Facebook
that would be involved in this it would
be a network of other corporations as
well so he was summoned to Washington to
talk about it and the Democrat people on
the on the committee figured that hey
we've got this the head dude over at
Facebook in front of us we might as well
take advantage and go fishing for some
sweet sweet sweet viral moments and
that's what they did so each Democrat on
the committee took turns grilling
Zuckerberg as if it was an episode of
Law & Order and most of the most of
their questions were at best only
tangentially connected to the subject
but in fact the majority of the
questions really had nothing to do with
the subject at all which again the
subject is supposed to be this crypto
currency thing that Facebook is getting
going but let's see what direction the
Democrats decide to go with this
questioning first here is representative
Al Green of the 21 how many are headed
by women congressman I do not know the
answer to that off the top of my head
but I can get any for you well I believe
you can get it mr. Zuckerberg but I one
would assume that you would know who
heads these corporations that are going
to be running this global company how
many of them are minorities mr.
Zuckerberg congressman I I do not know
off the top of my head are there any
members of the lgbtq+ community
associated with this association mr.
Zucker
congressman I I don't know the answer
who can who I acknowledge there are many
people who acknowledge that they are
part of the community
sorry God you do not know mr. Zuckerberg
is it true that the overwhelming
majority of persons associated with this
endeavor of white men congressman I
don't know off the top my head the list
of the people who are running the
organizations in the Association mr.
Zuckerberg how many women are working on
the project I don't know mr. Zuckerberg
how many members of the LGBT queue i p+
community work for it I'm not sure mr.
Zuckerberg
are there any disabled Koreans working
for Facebook I I don't know mr. Zucker
please tell me the precise number of
dyslexic Indigenous Australians employed
by the company mr. Zuckerberg can you
tell me how many bisexual polytheistic
one-armed Nigerian drag queens work for
Facebook you know here's the thing
by the way it's illegal for companies to
ask employees about their sexuality and
it would be extremely creepy if
Zuckerberg could provide a precise tally
what if he was actually able to say well
let's see here we have 52 gay people
we've got 30 bisexuals we've got seven
furries what have you had a list he
pulled out a clipboard so let me take a
look pulls the pen out of the ear
starting I you know that would be weird
we don't want him to do that now
Zuckerberg could probably actually
provide a precise tally of every
demographic group and sexual orientation
in the country because Facebook knows
everything but we don't actually want
that do we
and of course this has nothing to do
with the subject that he was ostensibly
there to talk about now let's see what
representative Joyce Beatty has in store
for all of us the other was around
setting up a civil rights task force and
who's on the civil rights test
Sheryl Sandberg is the person who sees
what's civil right okay we know Cheryl's
not really civil right so I'm trying to
help you here
she's our CEO oh and I don't think
there's anything and I know sure well
about civil rights in her background so
come better than that for me if we're
gonna talk civil rights it's an internal
task force you know who that do you know
who the firm that you employ for civil
rights this congressman I hope I don't
how could you not know when you have
employed the most historical the largest
civil rights come firm to deal with
issues that are major and and this is
what's so frustrating to me it's almost
like you think this is a joke when you
have ruined the lives of many people
discriminated because then do you know
what percentage of african-americans are
on Facebook in comparison to majority
folks do you know what the percentages
are people using the Facebook yes do you
know what the percentages are for
african-americans I don't because we
don't collect the racism well it came
out in a report and in the Pew Research
Center that was sent to you so maybe you
just don't read a lot of things that
deal with civil rights or
african-americans I have a lot of
questions I'm going to send to you that
I'm not gonna be able to get through and
I would like an answer because this is
appalling and disgusting to me and I
yield back
what I what what the hell is this woman
babbling about he's destroyed the lives
of African America Berg fan personally
but how has he destroyed the lives of
African Americans what did he do what
does he and the thing is he's got to
keep a straight face and no matter how
you feel about Zuckerberg he's got his
his his IQ is certainly probably three
times higher than everyone that's
questioning him but he's got to keep a
straight face and try and I I'm
impressed with that at least keeping a
straight face trying his best to calmly
answer these idiotic questions from
morons
he destroyed the lives of Africa there
was a Pew poll done about how many
African Americans use Facebook did you
read the pupae oh you didn't so you
don't like reading about African
Americans huh so in other words what
you're saying mr. Zuckerberg is that the
KKK is good guards arrest this man what
an absolute clown show I mean she really
implied that he was racist
because he hadn't read a poll about the
internet habits of African Americans she
really that really happened she actually
did that
beyond parody it is B how would you if
you wanted to make a parody of the two
lines of the two clips I just played for
you how would you do it you couldn't
because you couldn't make it any more
ridiculous than it already is okay let's
see what I Ana Presley otherwise known
as Ringo has to say about all of this
the same will bank reports cited in your
Libre white paper finds that almost 2/3
of 1.7 billion people who don't have
bank accounts say it's because they lack
enough money to open one so this is not
about authentication this is not about
banking costs this is about a tsunami of
hurt the millions are experiencing
because of a 1.6 trillion dollar student
debt crisis because of rising health
care costs and people having to use
GoFundMe pages to pay medical bills this
is because of the racial and gender
wealth gap so again you represent the
power but I don't think you understand
the pain there's under banking because
people are broke and so let me just ask
you this question yes or no is it free
to use the calibra wallet congresswoman
the Calibra wallet isn't a service that
is available today assuming we were able
to launch it it will be free so there is
no fee congresswoman that's the the goal
is to make it so that so there is no fee
congressman the goal is to make a moving
on so if it costs money to buy
right she was so proud of that line
wasn't sure you saw the pride or she
said you represent the power but you
don't understand the pain did you guys
hear that you hear that but you're
pretty good huh power pain that's it we
work we work shop that one for a couple
days pretty good stuff the rest of that
line of questioning was well I don't
know what it was
apparently it's wrong for Zuckerberg to
be involved in cryptocurrency because
people are poor and okay what does that
have to do with it's like if he said he
was gonna open a lemonade stand and they
brought him in for questioning and they
said mr. Zuckerberg do you know how many
people are dying of thirst in Ethiopia
right now and yet you want to make
lemonade it just makes no sense but of
course to call this questioning would be
doing them a favor this is not
questioning this was a speech that Ringo
wanted to give for the benefit of cable
news and she forged ahead with it even
though he rendered it moot by saying the
services freeze she said she goes
Zuckerberg is a service free yeah yeah
it's gonna be well since it costs money
then what about poor people honestly I
thought Joe did you know the Joker movie
was gonna be the most disturbing clown
show this year but the Democrats really
are giving it among a run for its money
if they really are and we haven't even
gotten to the star of the circus just
yet AOC first let's take a minute and
watch her pretend to be Jack McCoy mr.
Zuckerberg what year and month did you
personally first become aware of
Cambridge analytic oh I'm not I'm not
sure the exact time but it was probably
around the time when it became public I
think it was around March of 2018 I
could be wrong though mm-hmm
when did Facebook Co Oh sheryl sandberg
become aware of Cambridge analytic oh I
don't know you don't know and did anyone
on your leadership team know about
Cambridge analytic Oh
to the initial report by the Guardian on
December 11 2015 congresswoman I I
believe so and that some folks were were
tracking it internally and I'm actually
as you're asking this I I I do think I
was aware of Cambridge analytic as an
entity earlier I just I don't know if I
was tracking how they were using
Facebook specifically when was the issue
discussed with your board member Peter
Thiel congresswoman I don't I don't know
that you don't know this was the largest
data scandal with respect to your
company that had catastrophic impacts on
the 2016 election you don't you don't
know well congresswoman I'm sure we
discussed it after it after we were
aware of what happened okay it's so it's
almost cute in a way isn't it you see
that you think I'll she she she thinks
she's pretending that this is law and
order she thinks she's she's pretty let
her go she's pretending she's a lawyer
don't don't interrupt yeah but this
isn't a good trial
it's a letter have her fun let her have
her fun asking for the precise day and
time when he found out what what once
again who cares what does that have to
do with cryptocurrency and how could he
possibly know the answer to that
question now let's fast forward a bit
and get to a OCS irrelevant speech about
the the dangers of conservative websites
the truth is one question one more
question in your ongoing dinner parties
with far-right figures some of who
advance the conspiracy theory that white
supremacy is a hoax did you discuss so
called social media bias against
conservatives and do you believe there
is a bias congresswoman remember
everything that was in the Senate and in
the course all right I'll move on can
you explain why you've named the Daily
Caller a publication white well
documented with ties to white
supremacists as an official fact checker
for facebook congresswoman sure we
actually don't appoint the independent
fact checkers they go through an
independent organization called the
independent fact-checking network that
has a rigorous standard for who they
allow to to serve as a fact checker so
you would say that
white supremacist tied publications meet
a rigorous standard for fact-checking
Thank You congresswoman I would say that
we're not the one assessing that that's
standard the international fact-checking
network is the one who is setting that
standard once again nothing at all to do
with the subject these are not questions
they are speeches and her smear of Daily
Caller is absurd dishonest despicable
yet the white supremacist tide website
what is she talking about it and they
don't you got to remember these these
people are such liars and this woman in
particular is such a ridiculous
incompetent liar that there's no attempt
made to justify any of the lies being
told
none of them are worried about the fact
that they're telling obvious lies
they'll just at this point now even ten
years ago it would have been kind of
unthinkable for to have Democrats just
directly calling all of their political
opponents white supremacist and racists
and everything they don't get me wrong
they would have implied it very strongly
but this is kind of a new thing where
you've got these dem two prominent
Democrats that have no problem going out
calling everyone just straight up
calling them white supremacist no
evidence no reason at all to be saying
that but you're a white supremacist and
if the daily caller was a white
supremacist website what bearing would
that have on the cryptocurrency thing
we're talking about it wouldn't alright
let's move on
what else well I wanted to mention this
real quick it's not a huge deal but
yesterday you may have caught wind of
some outrage at LeBron James because he
allegedly disrespected the anthem some
people on social media were passing
around this this video of LeBron
screaming during the anthem and
apparently this is offensive and
unpatriotic and it's a sign that he's a
communist and so on according to the
outraged mass
that I saw online and well let's play
the video first and you tell me if this
is offensive and unpatriotic
now look I I think LeBrons antics with
respect to China or shameful and wrong
and cowardly and and I said so I
disagree with a lot of the political and
social stands that he takes but this
line of attack against him about the
anthem is pretty silly I have to assume
that all these people and there were
this was not an invented outrage now it
may be invented in the sense that the
people who are at who are acting
outraged aren't really and are just
pretending I think that's probably the
case because that's 90% of the outrages
that you've that happen online people
are just pretending because they've got
nothing better to do but there were at
least a lot of people acting as if
LeBron had done something wrong here and
I have to assume that all those people
have never been to a ball game before
any ball game baseball basketball
football hockey hockey isn't a ball game
puck game whatever because this is
really really normal at the end of the
anthem as it's finishing which is was
the case here it was the anthem was
finishing people start cheering and the
athletes will often do exactly what
LeBron did there they start pumping up
the crowd let's go doing all that very
normal it happens everywhere I assure
you it is a normal thing nothing it's
not a unpatriotic statement of nothing
like that this is just what people do at
stadiums where the last few lines of the
anthem are kind of drowned out by
applause and that's that's fine you'd
have to really be kind of a
stick-in-the-mud to go to a ball game
and people are cheering and you're going
shake pipe down folks pipe down
what do you think this is a stadium no
it's just people it's not it's not it's
not a statement against the anthem
people are feeding off with a patriotic
vibe and they're saying yeah let's go go
get come on you know they're it's it's
they're getting into it they're using
the anthem as part of that now if if
you're not allowed to respond to the
anthem that way if the anthem is such a
sacred solemn thing that it's it's a
communist to cheer during it then well
you know what maybe we should just what
should be singing the anthem at that's
before ballgames in the first place
because it's people are there to watch a
sport they're all wearing jerseys
they're getting into it and so I think
that's perfectly fine it's like if you
ever go to a game in Baltimore whether
baseball or football game this is this
is a also a common tradition where at
the very end of the anthem versus oh say
does that star-spangled banner yet wave
people will shout OH on the O line and
then because of OHS Baltimore Orioles
and then everyone cheers through the
last few lines of the anthem pretty
normal stuff I don't think this is worth
getting upset about okay one other thing
here before we get to emails I thought
this was pretty revealing Bob Iger CEO
of Disney was asked about the criticisms
by Scorsese and Coppola Martin Scorsese
Francis Ford Coppola of Marvel movies
Scorsese correctly said that Marvel
movies are not real cinema they're just
theme park rides essentially and Francis
Ford Coppola correctly pointed out that
Marvel movies are also despicable and
Bob iger's the guy who runs Disney and
thus Marvel he was not a fan of these
comments not surprisingly and he was
asked about it during some kind of thing
some kind of panel that he was he was on
yesterday and I thought that his his
answer was as I said pretty revealing
listen to this I just don't I'm puzzled
by it if they want to [ __ ] about movies
that's certainly their right I don't
know I don't know I just don't I don't
understand it seems so disrespectful to
all the people that work on those films
who are working just as hard as the
people who work on their films and are
putting their creative souls on the line
just like they are you tell me ryan
coogler making black panther is doing
something that is somehow another less
than what Marty Scorsese or Francis
Coppola friends before a couple I have
ever done on any one of their movies
like come on they said it
yeah so he says is to answer his
question this question is can can Black
Panther be considered anything less than
what Scorsese or Francis Ford Coppola
have ever done the answer is yes it is
definitely less than that I think anyone
with the slightest knowledge of movies
would agree it doesn't mean the print
that Black Panther was bad I haven't
seen Black Panther I can't imagine that
Black Panther was actually anywhere near
as good as people pretend that it was
but regardless there's just no having
not seen it I feel that I can still very
confidently say that it is less than say
The Godfather or Goodfellas which are
cinematic master the Godfather
Godfather's the best movie ever made in
my opinion I think anyone would put it
at least in the top five so is Black
Panther less than that yes it definitely
is but the fact that the guy who runs
this movie studio movie studio the guy
who the guy who's in charge of
everything the fact that he thinks these
two are the same he can't see a
difference between them in terms of
cinematic quality should really tell you
something and I think that this only
further vindicates with Scorsese and
Coppola are saying that these people are
they literally don't know what good
cinema is they think they can't tell the
difference between a movie about people
and spandex running around fighting bad
guys a movie that's made for
twelve-year-old boys they can tell the
difference between that and a cinematic
masterpiece to them it's all the same
kind of tells you everything you need to
know all right Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com is
the email address this is from from Matt
it says is it me or does anyone else
find it weird that the left endorses a
stigma free society however it seems
that they only endorse it for socially
acceptable mental health issues meaning
the right says transgenderism
transgenderism as a mental health
condition or
Michael Knoll says it is immorality to
use a mentally ill child as a
spokesperson for climate change policy
then the left gets irate with these
statements because they feel we aren't
accepting when they then be stigmatizing
if they are the ones when we say mental
illness they think of it as a slander I
feel that by them being accepting of
transgenderism that makes them
stigmatize mental illness when someone
calls them out on it that is a really
good point so I can see why your name is
Matt maybe I will take I think maybe
I'll just plagiarize your pretend that I
wrote the CIMA it's no that really is a
good point that in this was there's a
hashtag thing going on Twitter right now
or and I think it's hashtag end the
stigma and it's all about ending the
stigma of mental illness as you point
out this is something that the left
talks about a lot got to get rid of this
they're always trying to tear down
stigmas whether real or imagined and
this is one of the stigmas that they
focus on and I agree that a that mental
health conditions mental illnesses
should not be stigmatized in the sense
that we shouldn't alienate or
discriminate against people who suffer
from a condition that they can't help on
the other end of the spectrum though
that doesn't mean that we should
glamorize mental illness or make it seem
like something desirable or or or turn
it into social capital that you can
trade in for social benefits of we
shouldn't do that either
we shouldn't glorify mental illness and
the problem is and I know this wasn't
your point but the problem is that very
often when someone talks about ending
the stigma of such-and-such thing what
they're really trying to do is glorify
that thing so they're going beyond
ending the stigma they're not trying to
just make it neutral where we all have a
neutral objective view of this thing
whatever it is they're trying to glorify
it and that and that has happened with
respect to mental illness in this
country which is why everybody in the
country claims to have some kind of
mental illness and if you argue you know
if someone says I have this whatever and
it's a mental illness and if you say
well I don't know if that really is a
mental illness maybe it's not they get
very offended that you're trying to take
their mental illness from them so I've
gotten into trouble before when we
talked about for example anxiety anxiety
is treated like a mental disorder now
and I've made the argument that anxiety
I I have a lot of anxiety okay maybe
that doesn't surprise you so if it is a
mental illness then I guess I have it
but I don't think it's a mental illness
I think it's a normal thing that human
beings deal with and some people have
more anxiety than others and sometimes
your anxiety can be rather crippling
that doesn't mean it's a mental illness
though it's a normal part of the human
condition
and there are all kinds of things that
are part of the human condition that
people are going to have to varying
degrees and I think it's it's it's a
problem and now I'm going way off of
what you talked about but I'll circle
back around just bear with me it's a
problem I think when you take something
that is a normal part of the human
condition and you say that yeah this is
normal but if you have it too much then
all the sudden it becomes a disorder
well what counts is too much now you're
drawing some arbitrary line based on
nothing it's just based on a totally
subjective arbitrary line we're beyond
that line is a disorder and below that
line is normal and so we do this with a
tee a DHD we do this with depression we
do this all these things I now I have a
issue with that I think that that is a
that's a problem I think there are
problems with that now but the
interesting thing is anytime I have this
discussion whether it's anxiety
depression a DD people get offended when
you suggest that maybe it's not a mental
disorder why is that offensive do you
want it to be why would you want it to
be now I could be wrong maybe I'm ready
I'm right maybe maybe maybe I'm wrong
maybe I'm wrong maybe you're right maybe
it really is a mental disorder but why
are you clinging to it as if it's this
thing that you really want that that's
what gives me the hint that mental
disorders now have become a glamorize
thing that people some for some reason
actually want because otherwise I can't
make sense of that and and by the way to
say that again using example of anxiety
to say that that's not a mental disorder
that's not trivializing it I would argue
it trivializes it to call it a mental
disorder because now you're just
slapping a label on it you're
medicalizing it you're treating it like
some simple thing that can be medicated
and my point is I think it's deeper than
that
so I'm doing the opposite of trivial
trivializing it anyway in terms of of
your point I agree that if we are d
stigmatizing mental disorders then it's
why is it an insult to suggest as you
said if someone says transgenderism as a
mental health issue michael knoll said
pointed out accurately that great a
greta foon burg suffer eyes it suffers
from various mental illnesses which is
what the media has been telling us about
her so how is that an insult if you
treat that as an insult and as you say
aren't you the one that is now
stigmatizing mental illness great point
from Kayla says my husband and I are
huge fans of the show the past few days
we've been fuming alongside you and
whatever sane people are still left in
this country over this whole
james-younger case in texas i wanted to
share an analogy with you that I think
applies well and you should use with
regards to the whole transgender child
abuse going on around in our country I
wonder how many people would agree that
parents should not take their young
children to get tattoos if a
five-year-old wants a dragon tattooed on
to their face should the parents obliged
I think most people would agree that
they shouldn't why because children will
make dumb decision that they'll regret
later in life and it's the parents job
in some sense to protect them from this
and yet tattoos are much less of a
catastrophic and irreversible long-term
bodily alteration then puberty blockers
/ hormones / chemical castration
thoughts yeah I completely agree I think
I made I think I made this similar point
yesterday where they're all look tattoos
all kinds of things we don't let if
we're talking about
five year old kids six year old kids
seven year old eight year old kids we
don't let them make really any decisions
for themselves there's really no aspect
of a young child's life that we allow
them to exercise complete control over
they are not autonomous in any sense and
they can't be because they don't have
the psychological maturity for the
Argolis parents when our kids are young
is to get them to a point where when
they're 18 19 20 now they can actually
be basically a self-sufficient adults
who make choices for themselves we are
as children though we are equipping them
for that moment to send them out into
the wild wild world and say okay now
it's up to you to run your own life for
the most part but as kids they don't do
that so yeah you could bring up tattoos
any anything there are literally a
million examples of things we don't let
our eight-year-old kids do five-year-old
kids do anyone that age decisions we
don't let them make we don't them vote
we don't let them get tattoos we don't
let them drive we don't let them sign
put their names on mortgages we don't
let them vote we don't let them buy I
think I said vote already it we don't
them buy guns we don't let them drink
alcohol we don't let them do anything it
is a we it is a crime obviously if
someone has has sexually abuses you know
they are too young children at that age
are far too young for sexual activity we
all agree why is that and that's another
thing that really concerns me not the
only one to bring this up that's the
other thing that really concerns me
about saying that a child a prepubescent
child is old enough to make these kinds
of decisions about their so-called
gender identity I think that this is
ultimately all wrapped up in
effort to sexualize children which will
contribute to normal the normalization
of pedophilia our whole point about why
children prepubescent children are too
young for sexual activity the whole
reason we say that is because they don't
have the mental capacity to actually
consent to something like that that's
our whole point so it makes no sense at
all to agree that they don't have the
mental capacity to do any of those
things or to consent to any of that
stuff or to make any of those choices
yet they do have the mental capacity to
choose their own gender that makes no
sense
so what really concerns me is that the
people who are saying oh they do have
the mental capacity to choose their own
gender but yeah all these other things
they don't I think what we're gonna find
is that over time gradually those people
start saying that oh well no maybe kids
can do that and that and that and that
and we see where that leads okay this is
from Marx as Matt you're very critical
of superhero films I don't necessarily
disagree but do you like any of them
have you ever seen one that was
worthwhile and your judgement yeah I
I've seen a few superhero movies that I
think are would qualify as good films
everyone points to the Christopher Nolan
Batman trilogy yeah I think those were
pretty high-quality I do think the Dark
Knight is an overrated movie because
it's all really on the strength of Heath
Ledger's performance which obviously was
phenomenal but I think if you take that
performance out of the movie it's a
pretty standard by-the-numbers
superhero film other than that maybe
even kind of subpar in a way because
some of the other performances that
two-face aaron eckhart as two-face was
actually a that was a pretty terrible
performance and a horrible iteration of
that villain I think
not to mention he was two-faced for
about five seconds and then they killed
him so there are a lot of other things
going on with that movie that were kind
of clunky and clumsy and dumb but we
don't remember any of that and we're not
bothered by it just because that
performance was so breathtaking and
memorable and iconic so you take that up
but okay but still I would say that
trilogies is an example maybe there have
been a few others I Logan the mark
Marvel has made at least one superhero
film that was an actual real movie and I
think the movie Logan which which
actually did watch last year I thought
that was a pretty good one and I'll tell
you another one
what's like the the the cartoon Spider
Man film that came out last year maybe
it was this year and did really well to
box into the spider verse I took my son
to go see that and it was about thirty
minutes too long as these movies always
are but I thought it was an enjoyable
entertaining movie and the thing I liked
about it it was I think was ready to PG
you know as a kids movie and that's what
I liked about it because I think there
should be you know okay you've got
you've got this the superhero films that
like the movie Logan that's rated R
that's supposed to be more mature and
for adults okay that's fine
and then you've got superhero movies
that are really made for 13 year olds
but a bunch of adults watch them anyway
okay
there should be superhero movies that
are made for six and seven-year-old boys
I should be able to take my son to a
superhero movie and I think that's an
underserved audience so that's what I
liked about into the into the
spider-verse I thought that was a it was
a solid film appropriate for kids and
but that won't make an adult want to rip
his hair out so that's an achievement I
would say finally this is from I didn't
put the name down so I'm not sure who
this is from says hello future supreme
malevolent dictator what are your
thoughts about women posting pictures of
themselves breastfeeding online some
women seem to think it will help the
sexualize and normalize the practice but
I think it's inappropriate and actually
sexualizes it even more I recently wrote
a blog
about it and received a lot of pushback
by people who seem to think a lot of my
points were horrifyingly offensive what
are your thoughts on the subject this is
a subject that if I knew it was good for
me if I had if I had any prudence and
wisdom I would avoid this subject it
because no matter where I go with it
especially as a man it'll get me into
trouble there's really no advantage to
me chiming in on a subject like this but
that's if I had prudence and wisdom I
have neither of those things so I will
just forge ahead and I'll say that I
basically agree with you I think that
yes I think that breastfeeding should
should not be stigmatized some women say
that it is I I haven't really noticed
that I don't and it's not just because
I'm a man either this is something I've
talked to my wife about my wife we have
four kids she's breastfed all the kids
and she has often kind of wondered this
because some of the women that she hangs
out with will talk about the stigma of
breastfeeding and my wife will say
what's stigma I know no one's saying you
can't breastfeed I don't think there's a
stigma so I I'm kind of I'm with my wife
on that one it's probably a good subject
for me to defer to my wife too I suppose
so if there is a stigma on breastfeeding
if it exists anywhere that should be
stigmatized it is a natural healthy good
thing for a mother to do however does
that mean that we shouldn't practice any
kind of modesty when when breastfeeding
III don't see that and to make a point
of it to make breastfeeding into you
know you say that when I post the
pictures that it sexualizes it I don't
know if I would go that far but it does
just strike me as bizarre you're feeding
your kid you're saying it's a normal
natural thing so just do it why do you
need to make a point of it why do you
need to make it into a political
statement because either breastfeeding
is no big deal a natural thing or it's a
big deal but if it's a no big deal and a
natural thing then didn't do what you
got to do you're at home you don't need
to put it all on social media I just
find that to be totally weird
and and and yeah inappropriate and only
if it's not a big deal don't make a big
deal out of it and yeah if you're out in
public I don't see what's wrong with
maybe use of nursing cover or something
I I don't see why that is a problem and
you know one one argument you hear is
well it's a it's a natural human
function okay it is but there are a lot
of natural human functions that we don't
necessarily do out in the open calling
attention to it there are a lot of
things in that category
and then the other argument as well the
breasts are not a sexual organ and
breastfeeding is not a sexual thing yeah
breastfeeding is not a sexual thing I
agree with you but again that doesn't
necessarily mean you you know if you go
to a restaurant most restaurants in the
country there they're gonna tell you you
can't come into the restaurant without
shoes on now does that mean that is that
because bare feet are a sexual thing are
they telling you to cover your feet in
shame because there might be some weird
foot fetishist in the in the in the
restaurant who just can't handle seeing
your feet no it's just we don't go into
a restaurant with bare feet you're
supposed to cover your feet it's it's
what we do in a civilized society
it doesn't mean we're ashamed of feet
doesn't mean we're stigmatizing them
nothing wrong with having feet we all
have them but usually when you're out in
public you cover them at least a little
bit so I would put it in that camp and I
think I'll just stop talking about that
now thank you though thanks everybody
for watching thanks for listening and
Godspeed
Matt Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the Matt
Walsh show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey
everybody its Andrew Clavin host of the
Andrew Clavin show you know some people
are depressed because the American
Republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moon has turned
to blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]